there was a BBC news broadcast this
really happened and there was an
accidental they had some TVs on on the
background and they were reporting our
story the BBC and someone had True Blood
on in the background and they were
watching a sex scene with you in it and
this went out over the BBC yeah this one
on live television and in the UK on BBC
nightly nudes and it was a scene of
Sookie having sex with Warlow in the
cemetery for True Blood fans who know
what I'm talking about
so there's some quite distinctive
characteristics of exactly what clothes
were coming off at what points and what
color they were and how did you hear
about this in the UK at the time new
world yeah I shot a movie in Scotland
and so my my twitter feed sort of
because I don't know how like your
computer knows where you are and
hopefully when my kids grow up they can
explain some of this technology stuff to
me
but so although it's like getting like
notifications about like a skin too long
BBC and I was like well we have a clip
from the BBC news back let's take a look
cricket now and England have won the
fourth and final Test against South
Africa at Old Trafford they won by a
hundred and seventy seven runs meaning
they win the series three tests to one
Patrick Geary reports from Old Trafford
so basically what seems to have happened
is the some person who works for the
network was watching with her headphones
like a glass partition between the light
sort of whatever you call that sort of
open area belittling and I guess they
just didn't really sort of they didn't
think about it they didn't know but what
when I was was that the BBC was
broadcasting porn and people were asking
to have their license yanked right and
various things I bet they're rating
surge during that moment and I bet you
from now on I bet three years from now
if you tuned in to MSNBC or Fox News
they'll be small screens playing porn in
the background this is gonna be a
revolution look mister skin also
identified it for me I don't know if
you're familiar with mister skin well
I'm a frequent flyer I'm mister skin
because they really like True Blood yeah
so I was quite excited that like
somebody had sort of you know brought
this to to attention but also I then was
like holy those are my tips retweet and
I was like I actually claim my own booth
yeah sure come on empower empower
you